♪ ♪
>> Dana: BLACK LIVES MATTER
COFOUNDER CLAIMING THE RULE
SHOULD NOT APPLY TO THE GROUP.
IT COMES AFTER THE ORGANIZATION
EXTRAVAGANT PURCHASES LIKE
$6 MILLION OF DONOR MONEY TO BUY
A MANSION.
>> I ACTUALLY DIDN'T KNOW THIS
BEFORE THIS ALL HAPPEN APPEAR AT
THE ACCOUNTANT HANDLED THAT AND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS.
IT IS SUCH A TRIP TO HEAR THE
WORD, THE TERM, IT IS
TRIGGERING.
THIS ISN'T EVEN SAFE FOR US,
THIS 990 STRUCTURE OF NONPROFIT.
THIS IS DEEPLY UNSAFE.
THIS IS LITERALLY BEING
WEAPONIZED AGAINST US.
>> Dana: DOES ANYBODY WANT TO
CALL LAWRENCE WARNER?
DOES ANYBODY REMEMBER THAT
STORY?
>> Greg: HOW IS THIS FORM
UNSAFE?
>> Brian: IT REVEALS WHERE THE
MONEY IS GOING.
>> Greg: THIS IS PARTIALLY OUR
FAULT FOR CONTINUING TO OVERUSE
THE WORD WEAPONIZE.
BECAUSE NOW, JUST A FORM CAN BE
WEAPONIZED.
BLM USED HIS TEMPER BLACK LIVES
MATTER BUT NOW IT IS BY A LOVELY
MANSION.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT IS
REALLY GOOD.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
ALL OF US FILE A TAX RETURN AND
ALL OF US KNOW WE HAVE TO REPORT
INCOME AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
FORMS THAT WE HAVE TO FILL.
SHE IS TRIGGERED BY THE IRS
CHARITY RULE.
YOU KNOW, UNSAFE BY A FORM 990
WHICH EVERY NONPROFIT HAS TO
FILE.
THIS IS ABSURD.
I COULD SAY I'M TRIGGERED TOO
BUT NOBODY LISTENS, NOBODY
CARES.
>> Dana: AND WILL BE FIND OUT
WHY THE MANSION $3.25 MILLION
AND THEN SIX DAYS LATER
$6 MILLION QUESTION MARKS THE
ONE WHO WAS SELLER EXACTLY?
>> Dana: WILL WE FIND THAT
OUT?
>> Geraldo: THIS IS THE DEATH
MAIL AT BOM AND POSSIBLY SOME
PEOPLE COULD GET INDICTED PURITY
WHEN I WAS A LAWYER AND SOME
BLACK PANTHERS, WE HAD AN
EXPRESSION MAKE YOU KNOW WAR ON
POVERTY HAD BEGUN.
POVERTY, POVERTY IS SOMEONE WHO
WENT TO WORK FOR NONPROFIT OR
GOVERNMENT AGENCY BUT REALLY
ENRICHING THEMSELVES.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
EXPOSED HERE IS SOMETHING AKIN
TO POVERTY.
WE WENT THEY ARE DOING DEEP DIVE
AND THEY DON'T HAVE MILLIONS BUT
BILLIONS.
>> Dana: BILLIONS WITH A B?
>> Brian: DR. O'REILLY IS
DOING WORK ON THIS AND HE WAS IN
KENTUCKY STATE AND HE SAID THIS
IS SO OUT OF CONTROL.
THIS IS AN UNFORCED ERROR.
YOU HAVE LEGITIMATE MONEY IN THE
COUNTRY.
SO ALMOST TO BE A PART OF THIS.
AND I REALLY DON'T KNOW THE
STUFF.
I HAVE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
MAKE SURE I DON'T GET ARRESTED.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HIRE ANYBODY
OR CEO TO RUN THE ORGANIZATION.
THERE ARE ISSUES IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THAT MONEY COULD HELP.
INSTEAD OF MY PEOPLE ARE GIVING
MONEY AND FEELING BURNED BY IT.
CORPORATIONS, INDIVIDUALS, $5,
$5 MILLION AND WOW, I TRIED TO
HELP.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED.
SIX MANSIONS AND LAUGHED IN HER
FACE.
WHERE IS CORPORATE AMERICA THAT
WROTE THOSE CHECKS TO THESE
ORGANIZATIONS?
THE MBA ON THE SIDE OF THE
COURT, YOU SHOULD BE OUTRAGED.
THEY WASTED IT.
THERE IS A NEED IN THE COMMUNITY
FOR MANY.
>> Greg: THERE IS A LOT OF
CORPORATIONS, LOTS.
THEY WANT THE VIRTUE SIGNAL.
>> Geraldo: THEY WANT I
SUPPORT YOU.
>> Judge Jeanine: THERE IS
NOTHING IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
SCHOOLS OR FOR AFTER-SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
>> Dana: BUT THERE IS A POOL.
>> Greg: ANY TIME YOU EVER OF
LARGE CRITICISM HOW YOU WOULD
HAVE BEEN TREATED IF YOU SAY,
ALL LIVES